[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
ihrer paris guten abend und herzlich
willkommen das deutsche team bei den
paralympics konnte sich heute besonders
freuen die details von norbert lehmann
schauen wir also auf die großen themen
dieser sendung
die usa warnen vor neuen anschlägen am
flughafen kabul der deutsche
außenminister muss startet eine
diplomatische mission in die region
angst vor extrem gefährlichen hurrikan
ida zehntausende verlassen die us
küstengebieten am golf von mexiko
und doppelerfolg in tokio triathlet
martin schulz holt das erste
paralympische gold für deutschland im
tischtennis triumphiert valentin baus
gegen den favoriten aus china
die usa haben nach eigenen angaben einen
weiteren anschlag auf den kabuler
flughafen verhindert mit einem
drohnenangriff auf einen mutmaßlichen
selbstmordattentäter
angesichts der lage in afghanistan gibt
es morgen eine dringlichkeitssitzung des
un sicherheitsrates da wollen frankreich
und großbritannien vorschlagen das sind
kabul unter kontrolle der un eine
sichere zone geschaffen wird für
humanitäre einsätze luckwald über die
aktuellen ereignisse
nach einer heftigen explosion stand am
nachmittag nahe des flughafens kabul ein
wohnhaus in flammen das us militär
erklärte man habe mit einer drohne einen
es selbstmordattentäter angegriffen der
im auto zum flughafen unterwegs war
dabei sei es zu erheblichen nachfolge
explosionen gekommen lokale medien
berichteten von mehreren toten der
truppenabzug am flughafen geht
unterdessen weiter die briten haben ihre
operation beendet die us soldaten werden
bis dienstag bleiben der zugang zum
flughafen wird inzwischen von den
taliban abgeriegelt nur noch das nordtor
ist für personen mit ausreise papieren
zugänglich in afghanistan warten noch
mindestens 300 deutsche und nach
schätzungen aus regierungskreisen bis zu
40.000 ortskräfte und deren familien auf
eine ausreise in gesprächen mit den
nachbarstaaten afghanistans will
aussenminister maß ausreisemöglichkeiten
für diese schutzbedürftigen suchen zum
auftakt traf er in antalya heute seinen
türkischen amtskollegen kabul die türkei
prüft den weiterbetrieb des flughafens
kabul unter türkischer verantwortung es
seien jedoch noch erhebliche
sicherheitslagen nötig so javier mas bot
deutsche unterstützung an wenn wir einen
beitrag dazu liefern können nicht nur
finanziell sondern auch technisch dann
werden wir diesen weiter liefern auch
über eine mögliche ausreise auf dem
landweg wird mass in den kommenden tagen
mit afghanistans nachbarn sprechen
bundesaußenminister maas hat sich also
in die region aufgemacht fünf länder in
vier tagen als erstes heute die türkei
und usbekistan morgen dann weiter nach
tadschikistan und pakistan und
übermorgen nach katar und dort in doha
ist für uns katrin eigendorf was kann
maß bei dieser diplomatischen offensive
erreichen
nun es geht erst einmal darum mit den
taliban überhaupt ins gespräch zu kommen
wie man die diplomatischen beziehungen
zwischen den ländern gestalten will denn
die taliban sind zwar in der macht aber
sie sind ja keine anerkannte regierung
was in erster linie erreichen will ist
sicherlich dass die taliban ermöglichen
dass deutsche staatsbürger und auch die
noch verbliebenen ortskräfte ausreisen
können dass die taliban also bestimmte
sicherheitsgarantien abgegeben wichtig
ist dabei auch der mögliche
weiterbetrieb des internationalen
flughafens in kabul das sind sagen wir
mal die top themen erst mal für
deutschland die anstehen für die taliban
ist es wichtig anerkannt zu werden als
regierung das ist sicherlich ihr großes
ziel und was für sie auch wichtig ist
ist natürlich weiter internationale
hilfsgelder zu bekommen das wird
sicherlich der schwierigste teil dieser
rat dieser reise für außenminister maß
hier in doha vielen dank für diese
einschätzung katrin eigendorf
schauen wir auf die pandemie und die
aktuellen corona zahlen für deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 8400 16
neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das in
1366 mehr als vor einer woche
zwölf menschen starben binnen eines
tages im zusammenhang mit kobe 19 die
sieben tage incidents liegt nun bei
74,1
in großbritannien tut sich in sachen
corona derzeit erstaunliches dort ist
zwar die inzidenz fast fünfmal höher als
bei uns doch kritiker innen hat mit viel
schlimmerem gerechnet denn mitte juli
fielen am sogenannten freedom day
sämtliche beschränkung im land papst
clubs fußballstadien alles ist seitdem
voll die große infektionswelle blieb
aber aus vorerst es ist ein drahtseilakt
andreas stamm
ein langes wochenende musik ohne maske
auf festivals wie hier in redding
genießen 500.000 briten alle freiheiten
acht ihnen 200 künstler und die kunst
mit dem virus zu leben sein heißt in
kauf nehmen dass die korona kriegs für
mich okay aber wenn ich bei meiner
familie leben würde wäre ich nicht hier
vor dem bier ein pieks das festival im
zelt soll die er im müden unter 40
erreichen denn trotz sommer liegt
inzidenz bei 350 und könnte weiter
steigen das ende der schulferien naht
kälteres wetter dazu der wohl abnehmende
in schutz
sechs bis zwölf monate nach der impfung
können sich rund die hälfte dennoch
wieder anstecken und wohl noch mehr
wegen der delta variante aber der schutz
durch impfen gegen einen schweren
verlauf scheint viel länger zu halten
bleibt bislang bei ungefähr 90
das steht dieser schutz bei den schon
früh geimpften senioren fort wie schnell
kommt die dritte impfung davon hänge ab
ob
krankenhauseinweisungen und todesfälle
relativ niedrig bleiben denn hohe
fallzahlen allein beeindrucken kaum noch
jemand etwa das nach einem festival in
cornwall jüngst 5000 positiv getestet
wurden
wird an diesem wochenende nicht der
einzige ort sein wo menschen corona
kriegen sie werden sich in papst parks
restaurants bussen zügen anstecken das
virus bleibt für immer
und damit die frage ob das land einen
trügerischen sommer der freiheiten
genießt oder das normale leben mit
chrome
strömender regen in köln trotzdem haben
etwa 10.000 menschen an der christopher
street day parade teilgenommen auf einer
geänderten route mit größerem abstand
demonstrierten sie für die rechte von
menschen die schwul lesbisch bisexuell
oder transgender sind teilnehmen durften
nur geimpfte genesene und getestete
in den usa nähert sich ein extrem
gefährlicher wirbelsturm der golfküste
hurrikan mit windgeschwindigkeiten von
240 kilometern pro stunde zieht er in
richtung bundesstaat louisiana und soll
in kürze auf land treffen auf den tag
genau 16 jahre nach dem hurrikan katrina
dort große zerstörungen anrichtete die
regierung hat die menschen dazu
aufgerufen sich in sicherheit zu bringen
minibagger berichtet
hurrikan ida kommt mit wucht bringt
regen und womöglich meter hohe sturmflut
wer kann flieht die autobahn sind voll
raus aus der stadt new orleans bloß weg
von der küste
viele leute haben angst ich habe angst
alle hotels sind voll wir fahren immer
weiter bis 41 finden
doch da nähert sich schnell wird immer
stärker
lebensbedrohlich sagen die behörden
möglicherweise der stärkste wirbelsturm
seit 170 jahren für viele war keine zeit
zur flucht sie verbarrikadierten sich
heißt es nicht auf unserer seite die
stadt kann keine evakuierung anordnen
weil wir keine zeit haben
auch krankenhäuser konnten nicht
evakuiert werden zu viele corona
patienten für die es sonst nirgendwo
plätze gibt die menschen in lousiana
können jetzt nur noch hoffen dass einer
nicht so schlimm so tödlich wird wie
katrina vor 16 jahren
und nun kommen wir zu den ersten beiden
deutschen goldmedaillen bei den
paralympics in tokio fangen wir an mit
dem riesenerfolg für den triathleten
martin schulz der 31-jährige kam dank
einer furiosen aufholjagd nach 750 meter
schwimmen 20 kilometer radfahren und
fünf kilometer laufen mit 5 und 40
sekunden vorsprung als erster ins ziel
erleichterung nach knapp einer stunde
anstrengung
martin schulz akribisch vorbereitet
wegen der schwülen morgen hitze
trainierte er vor den spielen in einem
beheizten zelt zweiter nach dem
schwimmen im 30 grad warmen wasser
bleibt das auch beim radfahren und
überholt den britischen
silbermedaillengewinner george peace gut
nach der hälfte des fünf kilometer
laufes wie schon in rio 2016 gewinnt
schulz gold
und die zweite deutsche goldmedaille
holte tischtennisspieler valentin baus
in einer dramatischen neuauflage des
finales von 2016 in rio schlug er
diesmal den chinesen shao ning mit drei
zu zwei sätzen mit
diesen satz ball im vierten durchgang
macht valentin baus klar gold will er
sich diesmal nicht nehmen lassen der
deutsche gleicht gegen kaum nach sätzen
aus und ist im fünften satz der
dominierende spieler das kann sich früh
absetzen und verwandelt nach einem
tischtennis krimi seinen dritten
matchball zum 11 zu siegen er gewinnt
gold das erste für die deutschen
tischtennisspieler seit 2012
und dann gab es auch noch eine
überraschende silbermedaille für
deutschland in der leichtathletik
speerwerferin francis herrmann hat sie
geholt die 34 in cottbus wurde in der
sitzenden klasse mit 17 meter 72 zweiter
hinter der siegreichen chinesen lu chuan
so
und im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga bezwingt union zu
hause gladbach mit 2 zu 1 berlin jetzt
achter die bislang sieglose borussia nur
auf platz 15
radprofi nils polit hat die 36 auflage
der deutschland tour gewonnen der 27
jahre alte kölner machte nach 156
kilometern von erlangen nach nürnberg
seinen ersten gesamtsieg bei einer
rundfahrt perfekt den tagessieg
sicherten sich im finalen sprint der
norweger alexander kristoff vor pascal
ackermann und dem italiener luca mozart
tor das war's von fortis dankeschön
norbert und wir schauen jetzt noch mal
wie das wetter wird morgen ist es im
nordwesten bei 17 bis 22 grad freundlich
sonst werden nur 13 bis 18 grad erreicht
und es gibt viele schauer und einige
gewitter im östlichen bergland und in
den alten dauerregen ab dienstag wird es
von westen her sonniger und allmählich
auch wieder wärmer claus kleber brüste
hier um 21 45 zum heute journal wir
wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen schönen
sonntagabend und empfehlen jetzt berlin
direkt mit theo koll